voici un PC incroyable où vous allez
pouvoir avoir un écran avec de la 3
dimensions de la trois dimensions sans
lunettes c'est à dire que vous regardez
votre PC et vous voyez des choses qui se
détachent de l'image c'est pour en venir
manipuler c'est un vrai écran 3D comme
ce que vous voyez au cinéma avec des
lunettes trois dimensions regarder un
film différentes applications pour la
santé l'éducation pour tout un chacun le
commerce bref vous allez voir c'est une
petite révolution qui commence à
s'opérer et qui va peut-être arriver sur
une grande révolution ça se passe ici au
CES 2023 c'est à juste qu'il présente
sur un PC qui est démentiel vous êtes
prêt regardez bien jusqu'au bout parce
que les usages sont juste complètement
dingue
[Musique]
alors excusez-moi dès le départ je
voulais tout de suite comme on est sur
une techno qu'on peut uniquement venir
voir avec ses yeux à la caméra ça va pas
prendre super bien je vais essayer de
vous expliquer au mieux je vais essayer
de détailler pour vous compreniez
réellement ce qui est en train de se
passer ici et comment cette révolution
s'opère alors tout se passe ici sur un
PC de Asus le nom est un petit peu long
je vous le fais c'est le pro Art Studio
book 16 3D OLED on est sur une super
machine alors je vous passe la
configuration on est sur Windows 11 pro
on est sur une carte graphique Nvidia
RTX 40 70 on est sur un i9 de 13e
génération on est sur une belle machine
un écran 16 pouces 3,2k 120 Hertz bref
et surtout il est 3D OLED et c'est là où
la techno est belle alors regardez voilà
comment ça se passe sur votre PC vous
avez en haut deux petites webcam alors
pour ceux qui aiment cacher leur webcam
ici franchement ça va pas fonctionner
qu'est-ce que vont venir faire ces
webcam et bien ils vont venir
reconnaître la position de vos yeux la
webcam qui est située ici va venir
reconnaître votre gauche il va le suivre
la webcam qui est là vous aurez compris
c'est votre droit et va venir le suivre
et donc ça permet de construire à partir
de deux images en effet en trois
dimensions qui va être reconstruit pour
vous donner cette réalité ça marche
vraiment bien en 3D ça veut dire que
lorsque je suis là et que je bouge et
bien je vois ici l'abeille qui se
détache et qui sort si bien que lorsque
je pose mon doigt vous voyez je suis
encore loin de l'écran j'arrive même pas
à savoir où est l'écran là et bien là
j'ai l'impression que je caresse
l'abeille et c'est assez incroyable donc
cette abeille je peux la prendre je peux
la moduler je peux tourner je peux la
rétrécir je peux l'agrandir donc là j'ai
l'impression que je suis en train de
caresser l'abeille alors qu'en fait je
suis très très loin et alors ce que je
rapproche ça me fait loucher ça me fait
hyper mal aux yeux donc le concept est
juste Dingo et c'est absolument bluffant
ça vient vraiment ouvrir en fait des
perspectives parce que là il y a un côté
un peu démonstration rigolote jolie ok
je vois une abeille là je peux la zoomer
la déplacer si et ça mais je peux aller
beaucoup plus loin en termes notamment
de divertissement avec des films que je
peux venir regarder ici en 3D regardez
là typiquement j'ai un usage qui est
dingue j'ai avatar pas forcément c'est
le avatar numéro 1 de James Cameron
qu'on connaît qui est sorti il y a
quelques années où j'ai tout de la trois
dimensions et bien je peux venir
regarder mon film directement alors bien
évidemment je me positionne en face et
là je vois ce truc là qui va sortir un
peu l'écran et alors comme James Cameron
va travailler la trois dimensions
différemment de certains films plus à
sensation vous prenez la 3D un peu de la
tronche ça sort des effets tous les
côtés lui il va travailler sur la
profondeur de champ donc là j'ai à côté
dis merci et beaucoup plus de profondeur
donc là je suis reparti sur Pandora et
je viens regarder mon film avec cet
effet 3D directement sans avoir de
lunettes et je trouve ça juste génial
donc là on a un vrai usage sur le
divertissement donc on voit que si vous
avez des films 3D que vous voulez
regarder directement sur votre PC et
bien vous pouvez le faire tout ça sans
lunettes alors le truc qui est un peu
peut-être je pense frustrant c'est qu'il
imaginait qu'on puisse répliquer cette
techno sur une télé comme vous venez
capter les yeux du spectateur vous
l'aurez que sur une personne donc la
personne qui est à côté et bien elle
verra pas ça elle aura pas l'effet 3D
elle verra des images en décalé elle
aura mal au crâne ça marchera pas mais
si vous êtes seul vous voulez vous faire
un qui voulez-vous faire plaisir on voit
que sur le côté divertissement on peut y
aller on peut le faire et je trouve ça
juste absolument incroyable regardez là
typiquement donc là j'ai mis avatar en
2D regardez je switch ici sur la 3D ça
se décale alors pour vous ça a été un
peu plus dur là pour vous ça valait
beaucoup mieux parce que l'image est
plate mais c'est vraiment cette
sensation en fait que j'ai c'est que là
c'est plat je vois un film c'est joli
franchement j'adore et puis en plus
James Cameron a fait un boulot
absolument incroyable mais lorsque je
mets la 3D ça me rajoute vachement de
profondeur ça ça ressort c'est
légèrement devant j'ai le personnage sur
le plan là et ensuite derrière et bien
j'ai tout la profondeur de Pandor et je
trouve ça juste génial donc là vous
voyez au niveau de votre lecteur vous
avez une option entre in et out en fait
ça fait quoi ça fait que si vous passez
en in et bien on va passer sur la
profondeur de champ à l'intérieur de
l'image ça fait rentrer en fait à
l'intérieur de l'image et si vous passez
sur le out et bien c'est l'image qui va
venir couper un peu plus ça va sortir
les éléments en fait directement ici
alors vous vous en rendrez pas compte
une fois de plus mais moi je le vois
bien sûr que les personnages j'en peux
plus à l'extérieur et ressortent et
l'autre côté tout un peu plus intérieur
de l'écran on peut même venir moduler en
fait savoir comment on veut venir
positionner cet effet là alors
effectivement il y a un divertissement
très grand public ce PC là il va plus
être dédié pour des personnes qui
veulent faire de la création en trois
dimensions pas forcément pour venir
s'éclater si vous regardez des films et
des séries dessus vous pouvez y aller
mais Asus va également intégrer cette
techno d'écran 3D sur un PC un peu plus
grand public peut-être pour des créatifs
des créateurs allez savoir mais au-delà
de ça cette techno elle permet d'ouvrir
d'autres perspectives réellement plus à
usage professionnel là je vous montre en
usage qui a peut-être un petit peu plus
concret on est sur un autre endroit ici
sur le stand Asus d'ailleurs dans une
espèce de meeting room au CES vous avez
le PC qui est toujours là avec cette
techno qu'on voit au niveau de la 3D les
deux caméras et compagnie sauf que il y
a un partenariat avec une autre marque
qui s'appelle Z
je vais pouvoir venir choisir
différentes applications pour vous
expliquer comment ça marche dans petit
coin où j'ai le truc bleu je prends un
cœur par exemple pour de la santé donc
j'arrive sur une nouvelle application
j'ai un cœur ici un cœur en 3D donc je
peux prendre mon cœur je peux venir le
manipuler je peux venir le déplacer et
regarder un peu de revenir travailler
toute l'anatomie donc là je pense
notamment des étudiants en santé tu dois
en médecine notamment par exemple j'ai
mon aorte je la mets transparente et je
peux venir voir comment ça fonctionne
directement là je la vois un ventricule
que je mets transparent avant ventricule
droit et je vois exactement comment
fonctionne mon cœur à l'intérieur donc
là on peut l'imaginer une fois de plus
pour des médecins imaginez par exemple
vous avez un organe pour venir
travailler sur de la physiopatho essayer
de comprendre comment ça fonctionne
alors là je suis à 83 battements par
minute mais je peux augmenter et là je
vois qu'effectivement à 142 bah déjà ça
réagit pas de la même manière donc là on
voit que les usages sur le côté santé
médical c'est chouette autre usage qui
est très chouette et bien il y a par
exemple cette petite main bionique que
je vais vous mettre là c'est plus pour
de l'industrie de la conception je viens
l'éclater hop là je peux venir modifier
la taille de cette partie là par exemple
si je vais la mettre plus grande plus
petite je peux venir déplacer les objets
je peux venir aussi avoir une coupe
éclatée pour venir voir tous mes
différents objets je peux les saisir les
regarder les vérifier modifier la
dimension pour comprendre réellement
comment ça fonctionne pour la modulation
la création d'objets donc là une fois de
plus il y a plutôt un usage industriel
ici qui est fort j'ai un autre usage qui
est intéressant avec une petite montre
que je viens mettre là là c'est une
montre Breitling alors c'est du
Breitling un petit peu clinquant ici
vous voyez alors moi la couleur ça me
plaît pas trop on va peut-être sur un
côté un peu plus gris métal avec un
petit bleu au centre donc imaginez par
exemple j'en sais rien moi je vais chez
Breitling je dis ben tiens je veux cette
montre là je peux venir la customiser et
ensuite je pourrais la recevoir chez moi
vraiment avec les finitions que je
souhaite donc là il y a vraiment un
usage plus pour le commerce qui est très
très marrant entre usage qui est cool il
y a un petit papillon alors pour
découvrir de la science naturelle pour
les enfants ben j'ai un papillon tiens
comment ça marche les papillons ben
tiens je prends un papillon je viens de
comprendre comment fonctionne mon
papillon donc ça c'est très joli je vais
poser sur une petite feuille en bas et
je sens par contre c'est des vibrations
dans le stylet donc ça c'est assez
marrant je sens les objets que je rends
la petite chenille je regarde la
cheville à côté de l'autre donc là il y
a vraiment un usage surnaturel éducatif
pour les enfants puisque dans le monde
des enfants on va venir prendre le petit
hôtel qu'on met là où on a une chambre
un peu marrante une petite chambre
d'enfant avec regarder je vais avoir ma
licorne je viens agrandir ma licorne je
viens la déplacer regarder donc là il y
a un côté on peut imaginer un univers un
peu éducatif rigolo pour les enfants
vous voyez on a beaucoup beaucoup
d'usages et puis un autre usage puisse
lié je pense pour les architectes je
vais avoir une maison ici je peux avoir
juste le plan avec les différents étages
comme ça je peux le prendre le déplacer
je regarde je peux ensuite avoir juste
la structure de ma baraque ok c'est
intéressant ça marche bien il y a du
bois c'est chouette je peux mettre les
murs je peux mettre de la peinture je
vais avoir les étages je vais supprimer
les étages pour venir travailler et me
dire par exemple déjà je m'en fous du
haut comment est fabriqué mon bas j'ai
mon plan bref tu peux venir le modifier
je peux venir dessiner dessus je peux
venir faire plein de choses il y a plein
de possibilités c'est vraiment génial ça
ouvre vraiment ça repousse les horizons
alors soyons clairs ici le but pour ASUS
c'est pas de mettre des écrans trois
dimensions sur tous les PC non c'est pas
ça le but c'est d'apporter d'autres
choses d'autres usages je vous les
montrer ça va être du côté de la santé
ça va être pour des étudiants pour venir
s'entraîner pour des médecins ça va être
pour des architectes ça va être pour des
ingénieurs ça va être aussi pour le
commerce et pour beaucoup de choses donc
ça ouvre beaucoup de perspectives ce
qu'on voit ici c'est une nouvelle techno
que différents métiers vont s'approprier
est-ce que pour le public il va y avoir
un très gros intérêt au niveau du
divertissement j'imagine que oui est-ce
qu'il va falloir que des développeurs
prennent sans vraiment pour développer
des applications différemment peut-être
je sais pas on verra en tout cas ce qui
est super super intéressant et que
j'adore réellement ici c'est que ça
apporte une autre conception de notre
vision je me revois une fois de plus
avec mon stylet vouloir aller plus loin
et avoir un blocage physique un truc qui
marche pas c'est quoi c'est juste que
j'ai mon stylé qui vient taper contre
l'écran et pourtant j'étais persuadé
d'un point de vue cérébral de pouvoir
aller plus loin parce que c'est hyper
trompeur et que ça trompe mon cerveau
donc le truc est génial j'adore
l'expérience d'ailleurs vous j'imagine
que peut-être vous pourrez venir
l'essayer est-ce que cet ordinateur là
sera visible dans les rayons j'en sais
rien des grands magasins pour venir le
découvrir si c'est le cas allez jeter un
oeil dessus allez l'essayer la seule
façon de se rendre compte de cette
techno qui est folle c'est de
l'expérimenter j'adore ça je suis très
surpris je trouve ça cool c'est une de
mes grosses innovations coup de cœur
pour trouver ici à Vegas et puis
d'ailleurs il y a pas que Asus qui
présente ça je crois que Acer a
également un écran 3D je prends des
pincettes quand j'ai ça mais il me
semble qu'ils ont ça et puis on avait eu
des proto assez intéressant également
chez TCL qui a un très grand fabricandal
qui a des choses intéressantes du côté
de leur partie un peu recherche et
développement donc on voit il y a trois
dimensions est un vrai sujet un sujet
qui va se développer des usages
professionnels mais je pense également
pour le grand public donc on en
reparlera peut-être aura-t-on à
l'occasion de venir à tester ce PC
différemment et puis je vous dirai si en
fait on peut faire des choses mettre en
Netflix dessus est-ce qu'il y a un
intérêt oui non est-ce que c'est de la
2D est-ce qu'on peut faire des choses en
3D est-ce que si je veux me lancer
Avatar en 3D là-dessus sans lunettes
est-ce que ça va marcher ou pas est-ce
que voilà ça se trouve plein de
questions mais une fois de plus vous
voyez c'est là où la techno y est
intéressante c'est que la techno elle
vient ouvrir le monde elle vient pousser
un peu plus les perspectives elle vient
changer un peu les lignes je trouve ça
génial donc on en reparlera je vous
invite vous à me dire ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires est-ce que
ça vous intéresse oui non est-ce que
vous êtes surpris est-ce que vous avez
hâte de venir le tester et puis on en
parle très bientôt prenez soin de vous
d'ici là je vous embrasse et à très
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]